راحت وصلت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا
لينا بيربوك الى مدينه خارقاز الاوكرانيه
في زراعه في زياره غير معلنه نزلت خلالها
خطوط القتال الاماميه في المدينه وقد قالت
بيربك ان اثار الدمار الروسي عميقه في كل
زاويه وشارع ووصفت المدينه رمز الجنون
المطلق للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
والمعاناه لا متناهيه التي يواجهها الناس
معنا اذا منكرمه مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج
ادعمنا عمر همم اهميه هذه الزياره
وجلالاتها وفي اي سياق تاتي هل هي زياره
لوزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه الى خطوط
القتال في اخر
نعم ايمان هذه الزياره تقرا في سياق الدعم
الالماني الذي يبدو انه
الى حد ما غير متناه سياسيا وعسكريا وحتى
اقتصاديا لاوكرانيا هذه الزياره التي هي
الاولى من نوعها لاي مسؤول غربي
لمناطق حدوديه نحن نتحدث عن مقاطعه خارجي
التي تقع على الحدود الشرقيه الاوكرانيا
وهي مناسقه للحدود الروسيه وتعرضت لعمليات
عسكريه كبيره وميزه جزء من الشريط الحدود
اضافه الى بعض المدن والبلدات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه همم تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
الرساله من هذه همم الزياره كما ذكرت
وتاكيد على الدعم الالماني والذي يتفق مع
التصريحات التي ادلى بها المستشار
الالماني اليوم الذي قال ان المانيا ستقدم
على خطوات لدعم اوكرانيا بالعربيات وبي
انظمه الصواريخ طالما ان هذه الخطوه ستاتي
بشكل جماعي حلفاء اوكرانيا مشيرا الى
التحركات الالمانيه وايضا تحركات الفرنسيه
بهذا الصدر طبعا هي وقفت على مشاهد الدمار
في المدينه المناطق التي كانت قد استهدفت
وايضا المناطق التي شهدت عمليات القتاليه
بين الجانبين وذكرت ان هذا دليل على
الجنون الروسي وجنون الحرب هنا في
اوكرانيا وتحدث ايضا عن الدعم الالماني
لاوكرانيا في هذه الازمه ايضا كما ذكرت هي
المسؤوله الاولى من نوعها المسؤول الغربيه
او الاجنبيه الاولى التي تصل الى هذه
المناطق كل المسؤولين سواء من رؤساء
الوزراء او حتى رؤساء الحكومات كانت
زياراتهم مقتصره على الفيفا كيف في فتره
من الفترات ولكن الوصول الى هذه النقطه
القريبه من الحدود الروسيه يعتبر همم نوع
من الجرعه صح القول من المانيا التي قدمت
وما تزال تقدم الكثير من
الدعملي
لاوكرانيا على على ذكر الدعم اييي ايمان
لابد من التفكير بان المانيا كانت من
الاولى الدول التي قدمت انظمه الدفاع
صاروخي
وانظمه اطلاق صواريخ متعدده الجايبر بدا
اضافه الى الى المساعدات اللوجستيه على
مستوى الافراد وايضا الاسلحه اللي الجيش
الالماني وتعاهدت بتقديم المزيد وهي وان
كانت في مرحله من المراحل تعارض وما تزال
دخول همم اوكرانيا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
الا باجماع لكل الدول ولكن هذا تنتهي هذه
السياسه القائمه على همم معارضه هذا الغزو
ادانته وايضا تقديم اللاعب اللازم همم
سياسييا وعسكري لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
كيف يمكن ان تنعكس او نتوقع ان تنعكس مثل
هذه الزياره
وهي الاولى كما ذكرنا لمسؤول على هذا
المستوى الى خطوط القتال في خاركيز معنويه
على القوات الاوكرانيه امم هناك
ما يزال فيها شريط حدود يضيق يقع تحت
السيطره الروسيه وهناك معارك تتصف بانها
يعني ليست محددمه مقارنه مع المناطق
القريبه من خارج وتحديداهم باسوا همم ايضا
مع المناطق في فيزا وكذلك الامر في خرسانه
ولكن بلا شك هذا له دفع معنويه سياسيا
وايضا على الميدان على الجنود ذلك نتحدث
عن همم معارك الان محتدمه في الدومبوس
ومدن على وشك السقوط كما قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه في تصريحات سابقه لها هذا يعطي
دفع للجنود المقاتلين على الارض لانه هناك
دعم من الحلفاء خاصه دوله مثل المانيا
وانا كما ذكر سابقا فان المانيا ايضا
اعلنت عزمها تقديم مجموعه من العربات
بالاضافه الى تقديمها منظومه الاسلحه
مضاده للطائرات وكذلك الامر اسلحه بعيده
الدفاع
صاروخي هذا بلا شك كله ينعكس ايجابيا على
الروح المعنويه
للمقاتلين وان كانت اوكرانيا في كل مناسبه
مناسبه تكرر انها تحتاج الكثير من الدعم
العسكري وتحتاج الكثير من الذخائر لان
العمليه العسكريه ما تزال مستمره ويبدو ان
القوات الروسيه ادت عزيمه كبيره خاصه خلال
الايام الماضيه وما يحدث هنا في دون باس
وكذلك في الجنوب
ايضا في سوره التصريحات الاوكرانيه التي
اعقبت تلك الزياره نعلم بانه وزير
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه قال بان هناك ثقه بان
المزيد من المساعدات العسكريه الالمانيه
ستصل الى ارى ارضيهم واا بان المانيا كما
قلته او اسلافت بانها قدمت وقالت بانها
ستقدم المزيد من الاسلحه في اطار جماعي
مدام هذه الخطوه جاءت في اطار جماعيه كيف
بدات التصريحات الرسميه على هذه الخطوات
وزير الخارجيه الذي كان مرافقا لوزير
الخارجيه الالمانيه رحب بهذه الزياره وثمن
هذه الخطوه التي وصفها بالشجاعه واشاهد
بالمساعدات وكل الدعم الذي قدمته المانيا
منذ بدايه الحرب الى اوكرانيا ولكنه كما
ذكرت اردف ان ان اوكرانيا ما تزالوا بحاجه
الى كل انواع الدعم من حلفائها
لمواجهه الهجوم الروسي الاخير وايضا اشاهد
بالخطوه الاخيره التي
ساعدت فيها دول الغربيه من بينها ايضا
المانيا تقديم العربات المدرعه وهذا يكون
هذه الخطوه الاولى كما ذكرت هذه
المساعداتها الاولى من نوعها منذ بدايه
الحرب ولكنها بلا شك تاتي ربما قراءه من
الحلفاء لصعوبه الوضع خاصه في المنطقه
الشرقيه ويبدا ان القوات الروسيه
لهذه الهجمه وهذه همم هذه الجوله والدليل
على ذلك وما يحدث الان في
وايضا اا في ضخمه وما يزال كما قال الوزير
انه ما يزال ينتظر المزيد من الدعم في كل
المجالات من الحلفاء سواء على مستوى
السياسي وهو على المستوى العسكري بالله لا
شك هذه الزياره لها اهميه كبرى ان نتحدث
مره اخرى عن الوصول اول مسؤول
لهذه المناطق يعني باستثناء الامين العام
للامم المتحده الذي جاء الى اوديسا بعد
توقيع اتفاقيه الحبوب بين الجانبين في 23
حزيران هذه السياره الاولى من نوعها
لمسؤول غربي الى المناطق الحدوديه شكرا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات عمر الحاج مراسل
الجزيره لو كنت معنا من كريمات في سياق
التعليق على زياره وزير الخارجيه
الالمانيه وهي همم
اعتبرت خطوه جريئه